[Music]
today was a really exciting day for us
together with Google cloud so Google
this morning at the keynote announced
the availability of anthos anthos is a
brand-new hybrid cloud platform hybrid
kubernetes platform and we think that
anthos is going to be a game-changer for
the industry what I'm going to cover for
you over the next 50 minutes or so I'm
going to talk about you know what is
Cisco's partnership with with Google
cloud we've been working for over two
years on developing on kubernetes on Sto
a bunch of open source technologies and
I'll talk about what we've done together
to enable hybrid cloud for our customers
and and also I'll talk in more detail
about anthos and anthos and how that
integrates with Cisco's product
portfolio particularly on the data
center the networking the security so
going into a little bit of details about
Cisco's reference architecture for for
Anthes I'm actually going to actually
spend some time doing a demo as well so
if you haven't if I don't know how many
of you have attended previous anthro
sessions before I don't know if you've
actually seen a demo I'm actually going
to do a little bit of a demo and show
you you know it will show it live in
action I've also got a customer case
study a customer reference that I'll
talk about just briefly and then I'm
going to have you know pause for
questions at the end if we have time
it's a I've got a lot of content to
cover in 50 minutes if I'm able to get
through it in time then I will you know
take questions at the end otherwise I'm
available you know many members of our
team is available here are happy to stay
back and answer questions if you need to
all right so without you know without
any delay let's get to the details so
firstly you know the public lot adoption
is a given right all right everyone you
know 70 plus percent of customers use
public clouds today it's a big mandate
across the industry everyone's are not
paying are the public lon but everything
is not moved only 10% of the workloads
in the world have actually moved to the
public cloud so which means I still 90
percent of workloads are running on the
premise not just that many of the
workloads are actually moved have
you come back so about 80% of workloads
that migrated for various reasons
actually came back because they probably
migrated too early what does what does
that mean
right there - what that means is that
on-premise clouds and hybrid clouds are
going to be a reality and the entire
industry is realizing that hybrid cloud
is a reality and we all need to be able
to develop for for for that for the new
future which is which is based on hybrid
what customers are doing he'll they'll
run workloads in the cloud when they
need to
they run workloads on-premise when they
need to and what we as an industry are
trying to do is make it easy for
customers to make that choice they can
migrate when they want to they can stay
on Prem when they want to but we want to
be able to enable that choice and let
customers migrate at their own pace or
if they choose not to migrate and there
for security reasons or compliance
reasons they need to keep things on
premise you know we will you know will
help them and keep things on premise as
well so this is the vision that we'd got
together together with Google and with
Google cloud and we've been working on
this for over two years and a variety of
technologies and starting with
kubernetes and hybrid kubernetes with
ISTE or which is a service mesh
technology again driven strongly by
Google but where Cisco's a big
contributor and so we've been working
together on some of these hybrid
technologies for over two years but what
we are really excited to announce today
and really excited to share today is a
partnership
extending to Anthes if the name anthos
is new to you it was previously known as
a cloud services platform and I'll
describe what the cloud services
platform is but this is a brand new
hybrid cloud solution announced by
Google cloud today and this is the focus
of my of my session like what Cisco is
doing specifically with their dentists
so as a very quick introduction what
isn't ours um I don't know how many of
you attended the keynote in the morning
and saw the introduction but think of
what anthos is trying to do is provide a
ubiquitous environment across Google
cloud your on-premise environment and
other public clouds ubiquitous
development environment that's
consistent that's secure that's reliable
and when you build applications these
applications don't it doesn't really
matter you're not
developing for an infrastructure not
developing for a cloud you're developing
in general purpose applications that are
highly portable and what I'll show you
today is how we are able to build build
it once develop it once and be able to
migrate it to any infrastructure of your
choice or any cloud of your choice so
this is this is game-changing right the
ability to write applications right at
once and without worrying about
portability without changing a single
line of code that same application can
now be run on any cloud right so this is
truly enabling enabling multi klog it's
all it's offered as a managed service
Google Offers Google cloud offers anthos
as a managed service which means that
you can it you don't have to worry about
the software lifecycle it's all managed
the bits are managed by by Google cloud
so it's fully offered as managed service
and it has full access to the Google
cloud marketplace it has full access to
Google cloud services and I'll go into
more detail on what that means but what
this enables is true multi cloud
portability for any customer looking to
do application modernization its
application modernization is the number
one driving force and then in the
industry when customers and developers
and are moving from more traditional
applications to more micro service
modernized applications and as they do
that modernization Google Cloud together
with Cisco is making it easy for
customers to make that to make that
transition let me double click a little
bit more into into the antis
architecture so first lets you know the
applications are you know these are
containerized applications that run on
you know on container infrastructure and
the key element in this is using
kubernetes as the distribution as a
common infrastructure platform or the
orchestration layer to manage the
container lifecycle now so and what is
the the brand-new announcement with
today's you know with the with today's
announcement is that this container
platform the kubernetes platform is also
going to be available on premise so you
already had gke which is available
running in the cloud but now you've got
the ability to run the exact same gke
if you don't mind could you switch off
cell phone I don't think it's
appropriate to be talking on the phone
and they're under session sorry about
that so if you you know so to continue
where I left off right so you have the
you know the kubernetes environment was
running GTE which was running in the
cloud now with anthos you have the exact
same geeky environment that is now
running on premise so an application
that was developed on Google cloud could
be immutably [ __ ] can be you know
transferred or deployed in the premise
so you can run the application
experience looks exactly the same
extremely consistent and on top of that
along with you know Google clouds also
providing manage history of services so
those of you are familiar with history
and the service mesh what it allows you
to do is apply policies you have
consistent policies consistent security
policies for micro services needing to
access either other services in the
premise or services in the cloud
including Google cloud services a Google
cloud native services so the ability to
do minor managed IT policy managed
security for modern after application
environment in addition to this you know
anthos also includes monitoring
capabilities to provide you know
seamless monitoring across both the you
know the Prem environment as well as a
cloud environment and this is you know
very zero for firm developers very easy
to monitor the health of the application
the health of the infrastructure
completely consistent running across
both cloud and prem so this is the
overview of at off anthers right a
managed platform from Google that allows
you to do application modernization this
application it allows you to do
application modernization in place so in
the past when you are looking to do you
know modernization typically a user you
do the development on you know on Google
Cloud or GK but now if you don't even
want your developers if customers don't
want developers to develop on the cloud
you can actually do entire development
in the premise but if you want to
develop in the cloud you can develop in
the cloud and deploy to put into into
the premise or the other world other way
around it's completely seamless and
secure unlocking developers from
worrying about which cloud running on or
which infrastructure running on the
choice of where to run depends on the
policy set by your enterprise by your
customer your IT policy
SEC ops policy
we'll decide where you run it but it
unshackled the developers because now
you don't have to worry about where it's
running so it's right once deploy
anywhere and all the security
capabilities required by IT and sec ops
you're going to run in an enterprise
environment so just to summarize the
value proposition both for you know for
IT ops DevOps and for an for developers
really it's about it's a managed
environment run on Prem or run in the
cloud fully secure fully portable
supported by Google and this is you know
key value proposition of of anthos now
what does cisco being doing you know
together with you know with with google
cloud so when it comes to you know as
customers are looking to adopt hybrid
cloud there's there's number of
challenges that block or deter hybrid
cloud adoption the first thing is that
they have existing data center
infrastructure which may be legacy data
center infrastructure there's a need to
modernize data center infrastructure the
second thing is the data center is not a
place in the in the in the network
anymore it's not a it's not a fixed
location because increasingly with the
adoption of edge computing you're t-type
use cases
branch offers use cases the data center
is actually distributed cisco likes to
refer to it as a data center anywhere or
data center everywhere because now you
take your compute to where the data is
because you need to be able to process
data without having to transport large
volumes of data across you know across
Logan links so there are use cases where
you need to do edge computing and so how
do you solve the challenge when you need
to do edge computing at scale and be
able to run these modernize applications
on them so there are some challenges and
evolving data center requirements and
really what customers are looking for is
a private cloud or a distributed private
cloud because now the private cloud
could be in one data centers across
multiple data centers across edge
locations and you need to have a
distributed private cloud which looks
and feels just like the public cloud
environment is when you learn when
you're deploying applications we've
talked about security and I'll talk
about you know one particular use case
with security especially when it comes
to edge you know edge and branch
locations having the ability to have
secure connectivity between the edge to
the data center to the cloud and having
ubiquitous security across net and
threat visibility across this hybrid
environment is
to solve as well and all of this needs
to be managed so what we've done
together with Google cloud is develop a
reference architecture for anthos what
that reference architecture does is it
solves all of these challenges that
deter hybrid cloud adoption so starting
with a private cloud stack based on
Cisco hyperflex
and Cisco ACI so cisco hyperflex in Asya
this is part of the market leading
product data center product portfolio
that that VM developed and for those of
you who don't know Cisco hyperflex is a
hyper-converged infrastructure platform
a market-leading hyper-converged
platform available in the you know fir
for several years now but what hyperflex
allows you to do is effectively build
scalable private clouds on-premise it
can scale up to very large core data
centers it can scale down to you know
two edge locations or robó locations IOT
in our use cases so it's really a scale
out hyper-converged architecture that
allows you to build very efficient very
reliable private clouds in the premise
and ACI is our Cisco's as data center
Sdn solution which gives you the ability
of doing Network automation network
provisioning at scale and being having
the ability to automate across multiple
layers of the networking stack right
underlay networking overlay networking
container networking service mesh
networking you know all these layers of
that off the networking stack we need a
simple way to be able to manage
different layers of networking and
that's where a CI comes in so now this
combination of hyper flex and ACI gives
you a very reliable scalable simple
private cloud for customers wanting to
run gke
on-premise the second is Cisco's you
know SDRAM technology allows customers
to securely extend their their
environments whether it's data center or
branch and be able to securely extend
that environment across VPNs and being
able to you know connecting to for
example the me PC if you've got
applications running in the V PC
being able to create secure endpoints in
the cloud which are you know VPN
extensions from your from the premise
Cisco stealthWatch cloud is again a
leading solution to be able to do threat
detection threat monitoring in a hybrid
environment natively integrates with
Google Cloud V PC flow logs you can
monitor
you know traffic traffic patterns
traffic attacks coming in the cloud or
in the pram and actually give customers
the ability to you know to monitor
threats across this hybrid hybrid
environment and then inter-site is a SAS
based infrastructure management platform
from Cisco that allows customers to
manage this private log so together this
combination this reference architecture
of Cisco datacenter technology with the
Cisco Networking and an security
portfolio combined with anta's gives a
very simple platform for customers
looking to adopt hybrid cloud making
easier for them to you know build
connect protect and scale their you know
their hybrid cloud deployments so this
is the overall you know reference
architecture those of you are taking
pictures is probably a good time to take
the picture because now the build is
complete so you know feel free to go
ahead and and take pictures now all
right let's keep going so what does what
does this mean to you as customers as
developers as customers why is this it
what what does this give you what is the
benefits and what is a differentiation
that's the schoen Google Cloud I then
are are delving together
number one we are focusing on turnkey
operations we want the whole experience
to bring up the infrastructure to be
really simple right so what we are doing
working together with you know with
Google cloud is integrating anthos into
Cisco's management platforms so arranged
customer wants to bring up an instance
of GK on Prem it's very simplified
turnkey validated out-of-the-box fully
integrated and you know it comes up and
you can stand up a cloud on Prem in a
very very short time now hyper flex is
you know a data center solution that
integrates both compute and storage and
software software-defined storage
software-defined computer scale-out
solution but it gives you an enterprise
grade private cloud platform capable of
providing enterprise grade compute and
storage services to kubernetes even more
specifically you know kubernetes if
you're those of you are familiar with
the storage architecture of kubernetes
there's a newly developed container
storage interface or the CSI interface
for for kubernetes and what we're able
to do
type of flex is provide that storage
that CSI interface for persistent
volumes in kubernetes running on
hyper-converged infrastructure and
that's that's what we're doing so what
that allows you to do is that the
platform is enterprise-grade highly
resilient highly clustered and so now
when applications running on that
they're running with full resiliency in
an enterprise-grade hyper-converged
platform and I mentioned now you know
networking a couple of times but again
this integration this integrated
networking and security into the
platform really gives us end-to-end
architecture for for security and the
entire solution is jointly integrated
jointly validated you will see reference
designs reference architectures that are
going to be published by Cisco and
Google Cloud and we are doing a lot of
product integration in the backend and
over over the next few months you will
see more and more announcements that we
are going to make about further
integrations tighter integrations that
we are doing to create a really simple
out-of-the-box cloud for customers
wanting to run kubernetes on Prem now
just a small blurb on hyper flex for
those of you who are not familiar with
hyper convergence or with hyper flex so
just a brief product pitch on what what
this is I want I want I want I won't
spend too much time on product pitches
but just as an introduction right one of
the biggest challenges with traditional
data center designs is that it's highly
manual to operate and very very
cumbersome to build and operate
traditional data center designs and
that's the reason technology like hyper
convergence has become extremely popular
because what hyperconvergence does is it
basically immigrates compute storage and
networking in to us you know seamless
software-defined you know platform which
is very simple to build very simple to
operate there's you don't need different
you know combinations of storage teams
or networking team that's all very
simple it's all built on on a
virtualized platform and it basically
gives you think of it as a cloud in a
box right it's a cloud in a box in a
small environment and because of the
clustered nature of the architecture it
can scale out you can start with
something as small as three nodes in a
cluster and scale this out to eight 16
32 64 nodes you can build really really
large clusters and we've got customers
deploying this in hundreds in in large
core data centers
at the same time we've also developed
technology to be able to scale it down
to edge environment so he can run in in
branch offices and IOT use cases I've
got a very very interesting demo that I
want to show you at the end where we are
going to use hyper flex running in a
factory floor doing real-time
inferencing for machine learning use
cases and industrial automation use case
a very interesting use case and I'd like
you to you know pay attention to at the
end and because of this ability for us
to build this ubiquitous architecture
that spans across the data center to the
cloud to the edge we've thought we
define the notion of what we call the
distributive log so now what you can
think of is a distributed cloud for your
modernize applications for kubernetes
applications and complete freedom both
for developers and for the
infrastructure operators on whether you
want to run the app in the cloud in data
centers on the edge but you've got a
seamless ubiquitous architecture that
allows customers to do all of these so
just to summarize the value proposition
just a very simple one you know very
simple you know very very you know very
simple to operate highly reliable
architecture and very importantly it
does allow the coexistence of what we
what the what analysts call mode 1 and
mode 2 right so mode 1 refers to
traditional IT operations typically
these are running you know traditional
applications running in a virtualized
environment because customers are not
mud you can't modernize everything at
one shot right so you have typically the
databases are still running in virtual
machines they could be running in
traditional storage and you've got the
ability to have you know you know the
web front-end start to get modernized
they get could we get containerized then
the application services start to get
containerized as everything becomes
distributed you have to have the ability
to coexist existing traditional
applications with the more modernized
containerized applications and what
you're able to do with this architecture
with hyperflex is you can actually run
them on the same architecture the same
environment so you don't have to do a
forklift upgrade of your data center and
you can have a seamless transition
between the traditional world and the
modernized star and a modernized
application world and like I said before
highly scalable so it gives you the
economics of the cloud as well so you
can build as you grow and you pay as you
grow for those who are looking to start
small and and an evolve again a very
short you know pitch on AC I am
say ACI cisco's as DN technology and the
main thing the main reason ACI is
important in the architecture is because
you've got multiple layers of the
networking stack right there's the
physical networking or the underlying
networking you've got the overlay
networking and then in the world of
containers you've got the you know
you've got the CA The Container
networking layer and then you've got the
service layer which is at the layer 7 so
if you have multiple software stacks or
multiple layers of the networking
troubleshooting and monitoring and
providing visibility into that is
complicated and what we're able to do
with a CI is give a single networking
stack that's able to manage both the
physical overlay container networking
and service networking can all be
integrated into one stack so when you
need to troubleshoot when things go
wrong it's one you know one tool that
you go to to figure out you know how you
troubleshoot the environment so that's
the reason technology like ACI is really
important because it allows you to
create that ubiquity kind of vertical
network stack that allows you to manage
all layers of the networking environment
I don't know how many of you are you
know partners in the room but you know
what we've been working together with
with with our partner with with Google
cloud its create a very simple you know
ability for managed service you know
MSI's system integrators technology
partners to take this joint solutions
there are reference designs available
blueprints available or that will be
available and we'll take these and allow
customers to either you know get
customers started so you have simple you
know starter kits that are allow
customers to get started if you want to
actually go and develop the data centers
build the data centers develop
applications there are so you know
partners can offer services there and
then be able to you know implement the
broad set of application or services for
application modernization as well so for
again if there's any any you know
partners channel partners system
integration partners in the room you
know we're working to make enable enable
for you as well how to easily consume
and you know pass on the benefits to
your end customers I'm going to switch
gears a little bit now I thought about
the technology now I think this is the
more interesting part of it what is that
what does it really mean so I'm going to
talk about four different use cases and
I've got demos for two of these use
cases so just you know pay attention to
you know to some of these demos so the
first one and the first demo that I'll
show you is the ability to have
consistent operations across the cloud
and the Prem the demo that I'm going to
show you is how a single application
that's been developed available in the
GCP marketplace you can click pick which
cloud you want to hand that deployed to
and without changing anything you can
just take that application as it is and
get it running and you have a seamless
you know kind of seamless customer
experience a consistent experience
across the Prem in the club now this
ability to have the seamless experience
also enables other use cases for things
like if you want to use DevOps in the
cloud but you want to do production in
the premise right so you can do dev or
you know do the development in your
developers can build your in in GK for
example and then IIT may have an IT
policy that says this application needs
to be deployed in the premise you know
for sovereignity or security reasons and
you can have a simple IT policy that
allows you to do it but from a
developer's point of view he doesn't
have to change anything when it's going
into production because it is already IT
ready it's already data center ready the
third use case is is one way where if
there are services running in the
premise that need access to cloud
services that are running in Google
Cloud the eesti architecture actually
allows seamless I know seamless
connectivity secure connectivity between
services running in the Prem and Google
cloud services so you can here's an
example of either cloud or cloud ml
services or or big data services running
in the cloud and you got seamless access
to that so you unlock these so you can
still be running the application could
still be running on the premise but
you've got access to services that are
running in the cloud and the last one is
is where we're talking about using edge
the power of edge computing and the
second demo that I'm going to show you
will be around edge computing and how we
can use hybrid edge computing
architectures using machine learning as
an example so I thought that's a second
demo that I'll do so I'll show you use
case one and use case for are the two
demos that I'm going to be showing to
you
so to just describe and this is the the
anthos architecture that I showed you in
the beginning but I'm just using this as
a reference so if you whether you use
you know Google CI CD tools you know
using spinnaker to be able to build no
build and develop your own applications
or if these are packaged applications
available in the marketplace what this
allows you to do is you can have the
ability to deploy the application across
both the premise and the clone and that
is what I'm going to show you next
all right so as a demo kicks off
I had to we had to put this into video
because if you show the whole thing live
it does take a little bit of time so
we've put this into video so we can
actually run you through the through the
demo so to start the demo what we're
going to start is first we are going to
create kubernetes clusters on the hyper
flex system running inside the premise
and step two we are going to register
that cluster into into gke so you can
actually view and manage that gk8
cluster from GK even though it's running
on the pram so the first step in the
installation is actually to get an admin
workstation running in the Prem and
there's an install process you know that
to which we get the admin workstation
running once the admin workstation is
running inside the premise environment
there is you just create a trusted
create command from the admin console
and what this show what surely right now
is that the cluster creation completed
in the background one set so now what
what we've got is we've got the cluster
has been created running in the premise
second you actually go to GK so this is
running in the GK a console and what
we're doing over here is we're now
claiming that cluster into GK so there's
a two factor authentication get the you
know the the authentication token bring
that with register that cluster with the
you know with the cloud you're gonna
give it some tags because we're running
in an RTP data center and we've given it
a hyper flex tag to notify the third you
know to signify that this is hyper flex
and if you actually see here in gke in
the console you're seeing a hyper flex
GK on premise cluster running in and
data center environment and you seen
that side-by-side with GK clusters
running in a u.s. rest data center us
West region of
so now in gke what you have seen is that
you see both data center clusters and
cloud based clusters are all running are
viewed in one single you know one single
dashboard in your gke view now just to
confirm that this is indeed running on
the premise and one you're gonna do a
simple experiment we look at the nodes
that are running in the you know running
in the premise and you look at the nodes
that and we'll compare with the VMs that
are running in the hyper flex
environment and you'll see that the the
same worker nodes that were created in
the premise it's you know there's a
complete match between that it's just
you know just if there's any any
skeptics in the room just to confirm
that you know the the clusters and the
VMS that have been created by anthos and
you see in gke are the exact same VMS
and launch these are kubernetes knowns
running in a vm that is running on the
premise environment and let's go to the
last stage of the demo right in the
nasty to the demo what we are doing is
how we're going to take a package
applications to keep it simple we are
going to take a package application from
the gke marketplace to keep it simple
we've used nginx as the example so you
have taken and nginx in so we take nginx
from the GCP marketplace and we're going
to deploy an instance of nginx into the
hyper flex cluster running in the cloud
running sorry the hyper flex cluster
running running on the in the premise so
what you what you see in in that in the
next few steps is when you go to you
know go to the marketplace and pick
nginx out of the out of the marketplace
we can pick the cluster to which you can
deploy either you can pick a cluster
that's running in the cloud or pick the
hyper flex cluster that is the you know
the GK on-prem cluster running in you
know in the premise just change the name
space give it an instance ID and click
deploy and that's it
you have taken a standard application
running in the marketplace this could be
a CI CD biz custom application as well
but it doesn't matter once you've built
the application and it's available in a
kubernetes environment getting this
deployed and running in the premise is a
click of a button so this is where the
game-changing attribute comes in because
now you've truly enabled consistency
between the cloud and the Prem because
without changing a bit without changing
a line of code you have created a
consistent environment between the
and the cloud and just to confirm right
so what we're doing now is we've taken
the external IP of you know off the
engineering system just logged into that
and you can see that service is up and
running and this is running it's an
engine except ocation so you know it's a
simple example
but basically what we've shown is how we
are able to take applications developed
in gke and post that without with
absolute simplicity into a cluster
that's running on the premise so the
demo was was per the video was probably
spanning or running a little too fast
for you to you know pay attention so let
me just slow down and repeat this again
what you saw in the GK console was a set
of clusters some of those clusters were
running in gke
in the cloud some of those clusters were
running in a data center but it didn't
matter
from GK's point of view it didn't matter
from the application point of view
because now you can just take the
application and just pick which instance
or which cluster you want that running
and it creates a completely seamless
environment across both of them now
anthos is also going to be running on
other public clouds as well so now you
can take that same example and from the
marketplace once you've claimed the
cluster running anywhere you can deploy
this in any cloud or on the premise all
in the edge Orange or in Google cloud
and it's completely seamless from a
developer and operations planner tool so
this is really where we think that there
is this is this is opening up you know
game-changing possibilities for
customers that are looking to adopt in
an application modernization now let's
go into the second the second demo all
right
so in the case of the second demo in
this case the let me explain the demo
context a little bit before we go into
into details on this so the background
here is this is you know this is a bolts
application those of you who have done
you know I've done any any any work on
ml this is a standard application that
used to do machine learning you know
demos but the the problem statement is
this the problem statement is this is a
factory automation environment it's an
industrial it's an industrial plant and
the industrial plant is using a variety
of bolts now these bolts they they're
they have different metrics they have
different you know your measurement
dimensions right there the standard
dimension there's a metric dimension
to the visual eye you can hardly tell
the difference between between these two
bolts but if you put the wrong bolt into
the into the into the the machine the
you could actually have we could stop it
could stop production it could ruin the
end it could ruin the you know the the
equipment so the the ability to use the
right bolt in the right factory
automation industrial automation
workflow is very important now if you
leave this to humans to be able to
visually detect it's really hard because
as you can see the difference between
them is very very minuscule it's hard to
tell the difference between the two of
them and so this is a classic example
where you can do real-time machine
learning at the factory floor in order
to be detect the right bolt and make
sure that the right bolt is used I'm
just using the bolt as an example right
there are many many more use cases that
get enabled you know to something like
this but the point is that you we are
using the power of machine learning to
be able to do real-time image diagnosis
and use that image diagnosis to solve a
particular business problem and in this
particular case in this demo what we are
sure going to show you is how we are
building a hybrid machine learning use
case so we've got data scientists that
have developed I think the next line
goes into that in more detail so data
scientists you know there's the data
sources that's available if is typically
the you know the stream of images that's
available as a training data right
you've got to collect and clean the data
there's entire data pipeline work that
is that is required the data scientists
then develop the model - you know
there's training and then you develop a
model at the end when you need to run
real-time influencing that model does
need to be deployed into the into the
premise right and to into not the
premise that model needs to be deployed
wherever the influencing needs to happen
in this particular case we've used an
example where the the training and the
model development happens in Google
cloud using goop flow and I'll describe
described Cupra on a little bit more
detail but the influencing actually
happens on a hyper flex edge system
that's sitting in the factory floor now
because of the real-time nature of this
of the influencing it's very difficult
because as the the factory production
line is moving as you know as you know
these equipment the bolts are coming to
the line the latency required to process
these means that it's difficult to send
some of this transaction over to the
cloud or to the data center so this is
the reason
so I talked about some reasons what
customers may choose to you know to have
workloads running you know in the Prem
of the edge I talked about security I
talked about sovereignty I talked about
you know data gravity but latency is
actually a driving factor as well so
when you have applications that require
very low latency access to do data
sometimes it's not possible to run that
to run that it removes the workload back
to the club so it's a classic use case
why a combination of cloud and edge is
required to be able to solve a customer
problem now what's the technology behind
this all right so the technology behind
this is is an open source project called
coop flow so coop flow is a project it's
another project where Cisco and Google
have collaborated very strongly if we
have contributed a lot with a number to
contributor to coop flow after after
Google but what is coop flow coop flow
is basically an integration of
tensorflow
and kubernetes it allows customers to
build tensor flow models and deploy them
into kubernetes in addition to the
ability to just run intensive flow
models in kubernetes it also has the
ability to manage data pipelines as well
now again I don't know how many of you
are data scientists or machine learning
engineers in the you know in the in the
room but one of the biggest challenges
right you'll find that data scientists
are able to do the model development is
you know is relatively is it still it's
still time consuming
you still need time to develop it but
once you develop the model deploying
that to where you need the model to run
is actually a very complex problem we've
had customers come and tell us that it
can take six months or even a year
sometimes to get models running
efficiently in the infrastructure we
need the model to run so this is the
second problem that could that could
flow solves because it gives you the
ability to have these reusable data
pipelines and very simple capabilities
to be able to run these these data
pipelines in a location of your choice
right so in this case what we're gonna
do is we're gonna show you how we can
run these Kubb flow pipelines and
actually deployed on a hyper flex edge
cluster running anthos running GK on
Prem on hyper flex edge and we are able
to deploy these these cool flow
pipelines into into the edge so you can
do real-time inferencing at the edge so
let the you know I'll let the video run
and explain you know what's what's going
on in the background has to be as the
demo video is running
so first you are seeing the model
workflow that you can see in the in
encode flow let's open up the Jupiter
notebook right the jupiter notebook
which is used for the the model
development and it will pull up the
python code that actually does the you
know the coop flow pipelines are them
are implemented in Python code that is
running you know running in this case
the model development could happen you
know in any environment that suppose you
know kubernetes and code flow so here's
the kubernetes the coop flow pipeline
for the bolt image classification you
know application that has been developed
the next step is you actually actually
start the process of doing the model now
the model development is complete and
now you need to deploy the model so now
this what it is showing you in the next
few steps is the ability to how is the
house models
deployed into the you know into the
environment so you basically there's a
there's a click run and then you you
start the deployment and you click run
on the on coop flow and basically what
it is doing now is it starts the process
of deploying the Kubb flow you know the
coop flow pipeline is deployed into the
target environment so you can see that
as there you know as the video plays you
can see that you know the the the
training is completed the deployment is
going on and the services to actually do
that when you say model deployment there
is a bunch of services that need to be
running and there's a bunch of services
that get spawned up in order to
implement that you know the
implementation of the of that
inferencing workflow and so what you've
got now is now you go to the coop flow
dashboard and you're able to actually
see the models and you see that the the
you know the tensor board which is a
dashboard for tensorflow and now once
the model is running we can do a quick
influencing test give sample images to
the you know to the model and let's see
if it does the classification accurately
right so basically what we have done is
using coop flow the the you know the
coop the the tensor flow model has been
deployed to the target environment and
we are passing sample images to see if
the app the the model is able to detect
in real time what you know what the you
know what the type of bolt was but where
is this all running this entire
environment is running on a GK on Prem
cluster in a hyperflexion system
so if you see over here so the board you
can see that bolts application are the
gold side the bolt identification model
is actually running in a hyper flex gko
or you know GK on-prem cluster running
in the you know running in any location
and we're actually going to go into
kubernetes and start to look at the
actual services themselves so you're
gonna filter on the services that are
running in you know running here I'm
gonna filter for the class dinner for
the services that are running in that
target cluster that we picked which was
a gku pea cluster running on that hyper
flex head system and the video rent a
little faster than I was speaking but
what is what what happened at the end
was that it actually showed the running
services all the tensor board ml
services that were running as part of
that model all of that was running in
environment that is running on you know
on an edge cluster so look at the power
of what what we just showed here right
which is that from a data scientist or a
developer ml developer point of view now
they can build their training and their
models and they use the tools that's
available which is you know which is
time consuming in itself but when they
need to pick the location where they
need to run you know where the the model
needs to be deployed very very simple so
the power of anthos comes in here
because what anthos acepted do is give
that same consistent environment because
we're running gk on Prem we could
running GK in the premise am i running
GK in the cloud and both are running
coop flow they we've created a seamless
hybrid development environment for
anyone looking to do hybrid ml right so
this is you know we talked about the
promise of what this you know what this
enables and you know hopefully some of
these demos does that and it shows you
what is possible now when you have this
seamless or consistent development
environment that's available both in the
premise cloud I'm going to you know move
over next to a customer case study I'd
like to talk about a financial services
customer called key bank so key Bank is
a large financial services organization
they headquartered in the Midwest they
headquarter in in the Midwest spread
their footprint is across 15 states
1,100 branches close to 20,000 employees
a very large you know financial services
corporation offer a whole host
of all financial services no key bank is
one of the more I would say one of the
more forward-looking you know
enterprises in the world they've had a
DevOps team and they started kubernetes
and container development over four
years ago I'd say they're one of the
early movers in this you know in the
industry so there I would say totally
does when it comes to kubernetes
adoption and converting traditional you
know you'd assume that the banks and the
financial services are more you know are
more averse to moving to you know to to
some of those modernization technologies
they've been doing it for over four
years so they've been using kubernetes
for over four years right now and what
key bag did is they have picked and
thoughts on hyperflex as their platform
for deploying their micro service
applications in the premise data centers
now because of you know of multiple
reasons they need to have an environment
that's available on premise and first
they are big google cloud customers so
they do a lot of development on google
cloud they use gk very heavily and
they'd be the first wanted to build
environment where they can build these
applications and run these applications
in the in the in the premise and one of
the things that anthos gives you know it
gives us customers the ability to
monitor and check the health of the
application using you know using the
tools that we talked about like stack
drive up which allows you to monitor the
health of the application but the use
case really for them is the reason why
the the hybrid environment is very
important to them is because they want
to be able to burst to the cloud right
so they when they build their
infrastructure they size it for you know
for average average load but as the
during peak loads what happens is they
need to they don't want to build large
data centers to cater for peak load so
they want to be able to burst into the
cloud when they need to but the average
load is running on you know in the in
the data center environment so this
ability this you this kind of the
seamless infrastructure where you know
you have both the premise environment
and the cloud and you can burst into the
cloud without changing anything right so
you can have auto scaling capabilities
and with the auto scaling capabilities
built into the app you can build the
logic in to say just or to scale this
into GCP during times of load which
allows them to you know have the
seamless environment so it's a it's
another use case why it is important to
have a you know a uniform a consistent
environment across a crossbow
now why did they pick hyperflex right so
they picked the reason they pick type of
flex was because they wanted a simple
private cloud to be able to run gk
on-premise rights they wanted to be
simple they wanted to have all of the
you know the infrastructure capabilities
built into this platform very simple to
install it in fact this entire POC was
completed in less than two weeks time we
started we know we sent them my heart to
flex cluster as an initial as an initial
POC they brought up the you know brought
up the hyper flex system in let in in a
few hours they deployed they deployed GK
on Prem on to that cluster and they
started migrating their kubernetes
applications to the environment this POC
has completed successfully very very you
know the speed at which the POC
completed and the ease at which they
were able to do it you know goes back to
some of the things that we said in the
past which is our goal is how easy do we
make it for customers to be able to
build these cloud environments
on-premise so really simple you know
environment to be able to bring up these
these applications and of course for
then the reliability was highly
important as well right because of the
clustered nature of the hyper flex
architecture when it is zero downtime
application upgrades can happen without
requiring cluster downtime
infrastructure upgrades can happen
without requiring cluster downtime so
you can do come you know compute and
talk about computing into firmware
upgrades you can do storage upgrades all
of that while applications continue to
run so the ability to do zero downtime
of bridge was extremely important so
really this is again bringing one of
those cloud attributes to the premise
because now this is a cloud it not
doesn't go down even if you're doing
things in the infrastructure the cluster
always stays up applications always stay
up so it is 0 tau zero downtime
environment for you know for customers
looking to get that cloud experience on
time so you know this is a a great
example of a customer that went through
the journey of evaluating why do they
want a hybrid cloud architecture and why
they picked anthos and hyper flex as the
platform's to do you know to do hybrid
cloud so to
you know what what do you need to do to
get started you know to get started
first of all we've got value validated
designs in our reference architectures
together with Cisco and Google cloud and
and this platforms have been validated
they've been tested so you get you know
validated hardware or you will get once
it's general available it will use you
know you know in a few months it's going
to be general availability and so you'll
get all of this available simple
seamless out-of-the-box and you can
purchase this either through you know
through Cisco or you can power your
purchase it through Google you buy the
you know either the Cisco product from
Cisco and you buys anthos from from
Google and it'll be jointly supported by
Cisco and Google technical support right
so this is this is what it takes to get
started very simple for you to get
started if you if you choose to you know
and jointly supported by my both just go
on Google and Google Cloud if you're
interested in getting more information
you know you can start with some of the
you know the product URLs you know that
you've got URLs both on the Google
website as well as on the Cisco website
on how to get more information there's a
training a program there's a CSP or and
thoughts training program that's
actually scheduled for later this month
those of you who are interested in
getting more hands-on experience there
is a training program that's available
and there'll be a series of other
trainings that'll you know that will be
available and you know you can get you
know get started and you know get your
hands you know get your hands dirty with
with trying on some of this new
technology just a very lost you know
update that this is this one is not
relevant not directly relevant to Anthes
but you know Cisco also has a number of
other offers that are available in the
Google cloud marketplace AppDynamics
which is an application monitoring
solution stealthWatch cloud which I
talked about previously which is are a
threat mod a threat monitoring solution
and the cloud services router are all
available on the Cisco marketplace and
today we also announce the availability
of WebEx our collaboration suite
on the G suite marketplace as well so
you know a whole host of you know other
things that Cisco and Google are
collaborating on oh it's just going
Google Cloud or collaborating on when it
comes to you know your joint technology
joint integration between our between
our companies so the last thing that
we'd like you to take away is
joint solution between Google cloud and
Cisco with anthos and hyper flex and
Asya and the other Cisco you know you
know technology allows customers to
adopt the next generation of hybrid
cloud which allows developers to build
once deploy anywhere complete freedom of
where the applications are running and
this is jointly developed engineered and
supported by Cisco and Google Cloud
[Music]